yesterday we told you about the R B
singer Neo whose name I learned this
week is actually spelled n-e-y-o and um
he said in an interview a few a few days
ago that children can't choose their
gender and they can't transition and you
shouldn't castrate little kids uh Etc
you know a bunch of extremely Common
Sense things uh and and opinions on on
the subject
and opinions that we shouldn't be
impressed by shouldn't impress us that
someone is coming out and saying oh you
know a five-year-old boy is a boy and
can't be a girl
but it does impress us coming from a
celebrity because most celebrities are
degenerate lunatics and it turns out
that Neo isn't and that's uh that's a
good thing
so the expected backlash ensued and then
as we covered yesterday Neo posted an
apology rather quickly to the LGBT
community as I know the lgbtqia plus
Community spelled it all out and he
apologized for offending them and all
the rest of it and I criticized them
harshly on this show for that and so did
thousands of other people
then yesterday afternoon after uh this
show went out
Neo posted another video and this one on
his Instagram I believe
uh and and this video is being shared by
conservatives who are back to
celebrating Neo again and they say that
that in this video
Neo repudiates his publicist who's the
one who is responsible for the apology
any any and he slams The publicist bla I
saw someone post he blasts his publicist
and he doubles down again on his
original point about not transitioning
kids
that's that's what people are saying
about the video that's how it's being
interpreted
but here's what he actually said and you
tell me what he's what how you take this
go ahead
what's going on loved ones this is Neo
all right listen I normally don't give
too much of a damn about what y'all
think about what I do what y'all have to
say about what I say whatever I normally
don't care because like I said opinions
ain't special everybody got one however
this is something I feel very strongly
on and I need y'all to hear this from
the horse's mouth not the publicist
computer so check this out first and
foremost I do not apologize for having
an opinion on this matter I am a 43 year
old heterosexual man raising five boys
and two girls okay that's my reality now
if my opinion offended somebody yeah
sure I apologize for you being offended
because that wasn't my intention my
intention is never to offend anybody
however I'm entitled to feel how I feel
I'm absolutely entitled to feel how I
feel the same way you are entitled to
feel how you feel I ain't asked nobody
to follow me I ain't ask nobody to agree
with me I was asked a question and I
answered the damn question okay I have
no beef with the
lbgtqia plus Community whatsoever I
ain't got no beef with y'all do whatever
the hell it is you want to do do what
you want to do with your kids however
somebody asked my opinion on this matter
and this is how I feel I will never be
okay with allowing a child to make a
decision that detrimental to their life
I will never be okay with that I don't I
I definitely plan to educate myself a
little bit more on this matter however I
doubt that there's any book anywhere or
any opinion that somebody's gonna tell
me that's gonna make me okay with
letting the child make a decision like
that that's just period Point Blank and
that's how I feel if I get canceled for
this then you know what maybe this is a
world where they don't need a Neo no
more all right and I got no problem with
that I'm a hustler all right I'll figure
it out I got kids to raise and I'm gonna
do that regardless so with that being
said
y'all have a good day I love everybody
live how you want to live love how you
want to love but your opinion is yours
speak your opinion as much as you damn
well feel like it because as I said
they're not important they're not
special everybody got one and you're
entitled to it I'm entitled to mine all
right y'all feel how y'all want to feel
have a great day it's Neo peace and love
okay so that's the video again it's
being posted all over the place by
conservatives
this is epic listen to this
not exactly the Epic slapdown of his
publicist that we were led to believe in
fact it's pretty clear to me that he
consented to the apology being posted
okay so this is not him saying I didn't
even know if the public was going to do
that he's fired for deal for for posting
an apology on my behalf without my
consent that's not what happened he's
justifying and trying to explain what is
in the apology and yes he says it was
posted from from his publicist computer
he never says that he didn't agree to it
because obviously he did agree to it you
know your publicist let me explain to
you how these things work your publicist
is not going to just go on his own
and uh and post an apology without you
even knowing about it that's not going
to happen
um I can tell you you know we have
plenty of publicist PR people to work
daily wire if they were to when this
would never happen but if they were to
post an apology from me
on one of my accounts that I didn't
agree to and I never would agree to one
then
my response would not be that okay I
would go nuclear okay I you would have
no idea
how much of an explosion of Rage that
would cause I mean for one thing I
delete the apology uh I would have much
stronger words than that and I would say
the daily wire you need to fire the
person who did that or I quit you know
that's what it would be now Neo is in
the position where he could just fire
his publishes outright and uh but he
didn't do that either at least he didn't
say that he did so because again he he
agreed to that apology he might have
been they might have uh pressured him
I'm sure they pressured him I'm sure
they tried to coerce him I'm sure they
tried to convince him look you got to do
this you're going to lose money you're
going to lose sponsorships if you don't
do it so I'm sure all that happened
but he agreed to it you've probably
heard by now that you should be using a
VPN when you connect to the internet but
if you're like me adding an extra step
to anything you do every day just sounds
like a hassle well if you knew how easy
it was to protect your connection with
expressvpn you'd be doing it already
expressvpn is the easiest way to browse
safely securely and just better
expressvpn gets rid of all those things
you hate about vpns is a VPN done right
first of all it's blazing fast a lot of
other vpns slow your connection to the
point where it's not even worth it to
connect anymore but expressvpn does not
lag or buffer you can stream in HD with
no issues and using it couldn't be
easier just open the express would be an
app click one button enjoy instant
protection across all your devices it's
that simple once you connect to
expressvpn you don't even realize you
have it on but your connection is secure
and your data is encrypted no wonder
it's been called the best VPN by CNET
visit expressvpn.com Walsh right now to
get three extra months free that's
expressvpn.com walls to get protected
expressvpn.com Welsh so what's happening
here is that Neo said something about
the trans issue
panicked at the backlash from the left
on what he said
and then
posted an apology and then panicked
again at the backlash against the
apology so that's why I was bouncing
back and forth like a pinball it's not
it's not really that confusing
all the while uh he knows what's right
and wrong on this issue issue it's very
clear he knows what's right and wrong he
knows the truth and he's trying and
fumbling in his attempt to sort of Stand
by it
um he's obviously never experienced the
Wrath of the LGBT cult those of us who
live with it every day are used to it he
isn't and so I always try to keep that
in mind there are people even people
that are famous and been in public eye
for a long time uh if you've never
if you if you've never upset this
particular mob then you just don't quite
know
what all goes on in behind the scenes as
well
this is not just about mean comments on
Twitter or whatever that's the least of
it
so all that's the case
but this is not this isn't this this is
not we don't congratulate him for this
whole performance this is the initial
statement was right everything after
that is just like embarrassing and
waffling and he's trying to triangulate
and find a position that'll make
everybody happy he's trying to appease
everyone this is not we don't you should
be congratulating him for that
um
and it goes to show
why the only thing that works is a
strong hard-line unwavering stance Neo
is trying to claim a kind of libertarian
position here and this is why this story
is important whether you know whatever
even if you don't care about Neo what if
it you know it's not like I'm sitting
around paying attention to what's going
on with Neo
um
but it's important because of what we
can learn from this which is that
this kind of libertarian position
doesn't work that's what he's trying to
do right he's saying well hey everyone
has their opinion I have mine everyone
just leave everyone else alone let's all
be happy let's all get along do what you
want with your own kids he even says
that
uh
and there are people have told me well
don't criticize Neo for this he's your
ally no no he's not that's not my that's
not even close to my position do what
you want with your own kids
that's the opposite of what I think
about this no I don't think you should
be able to just do what you want with
your own kids I don't think you should
be able to transition your kids even if
you want to
and if you think that people should be
allowed to do that then no we're really
not allies we don't share where's our
where's our Common Ground exactly
um but he's trying to kind of do this
hey I have my opinion you have your
opinion let's all have our opinions we
have we all have a right to our opinion
I mean like the first of all the moment
you say that the moment you find
yourself saying we all have a right to
our opinion
okay that that is the ultimate
sign of weakness the moment you you find
yourself saying that in an argument
you're losing
there's no better sign than you're that
you're losing than when you say well I
have a right to my opinion
that's the weakest stance that that is
you backtracking while trying to pretend
that you're not
um
and he's confused as to why that's not
good enough for the left well it's not
good enough because they want nothing
less than your unthinking unyielding
loyalty anything less than that and you
are the enemy
so no you can't just have your own
opinion they're not going to accept that
you you can't go out there and say uh
boys are boys girls are girls but hey
just my opinion you can feel all you
want you can't qualify it that way and
expect that they're gonna be okay but
what do you think they're going to say
then they're going to say well it's just
your opinion that's fine
hey look everyone everyone can have
their own view on this you can guess
what the trans activists are going to
say when have you ever known a trans
activist to respond that way was the
last time you heard a trans activists
say hey look everyone has a right to
their own opinion and look I respect
your view on this they are never going
to say that that is not what they're
going to say you must bow before them
you must bow at their feet and if you
don't do that you are their enemy it's
the those are the two choices they
haven't left you a middle ground
um which is why the only thing that
makes logical and moral sense not to
mention strategic sense it's just the
only thing that makes sense is to take
this hard-line stance
and and uh and
and that's it
I mean do what you want with your own
kids
you realize the kids are too young to
make these choices you realize that
transitioning a child is abusive and yet
you're saying that people should be able
to do that to their kids if they want so
people should be able to abuse their
kids if they want to
that doesn't make sense
here's the only thing that makes sense
Neo and it's it's uh
clear what you actually think but you
don't want to go all the way and say
this but you should
transitioning kids is abusive
nobody should be allowed to do it to
their kids
everyone has their own opinion about
this but if your opinion is that it's
okay to sterilize and castrate kids and
dress little boys up like girls and so
on
then your opinion is wrong and also
insane
you're allowed to have that opinion
can't stop you from having any opinion
you want but it's a wrong opinion it's a
bad opinion
in fact it's an opinion that shows that
you are a bad person it's a disgusting
opinion that reflects some very ugly
things about you and your character and
your morals
and if you are doing this to your
children you need to stop you abusive
psychopath
and the law should stop you should be
thrown in prison for it that's what you
should be saying
that's clearly what you think
okay if you know that this that this
stuff is tantamount to the not tandemon
if you know that this is sterilization
castration mutilation kids aren't old
enough like you know it's abusive
uh I I just I don't believe you that you
think that people should be able to
abuse their kids if they want I don't
think you actually think that that
doesn't make any sense
um
so you might as well again the middle
ground as I'm always preaching the
middle ground is not available okay it's
it's there isn't one
you're trying to stake out a position
that doesn't really exist
so
go all the way with what you think
and actually stand by it
without any kind of apology not even an
APO I'm sorry if your feelings were hurt
I'm not I'm not sorry for feelings are
you really Neil are you actually you
said some really Common Sense things as
you point out
you're they asked your opinion and you
you gave it
and then a bunch of morons start crying
about it
because you said you said that you
shouldn't dress a five-year-old boy up
like a girl
and a bunch of morons are crying and are
offended by it and you're sorry for
their heart hurt feelings are you really
really you're sorry
you feel so oh I'm so sorry that you're
in pain over this really is that I don't
think it is
I can't read your mind I don't think
you're really sorry that their opinions
that their feelings were hurt and if you
are you shouldn't be
I'll tell you one thing for sure when I
say something that is true and just
basic common sense
if your feelings are hurt by it I am not
sorry and I don't care because that's
your issue that's your problem it's not
mine
that's something you need to fix it's
not my issue
and the fact that you are so deranged
as to believe that it's okay to abuse
kids in this way
and the fact that you're so immature
as to think that you should be able to
control other people's opinions
basically because it makes you feel bad
if they have an opinion of disagreement
disagrees with you all of that is your
issue
not mine
the only position that makes sense
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there